juntar doscientas mil tropas alrededor
de toda ucrania desde el norte del este
del sur no se hace ni en dos semanas ni
en un mes lleva desde diciembre amasando
tropas en las fronteras ucranianas y
bueno para que quiere uno 200 mil tropas
si no es para invadir al país a mí me
parece que los reportes de inteligencia
occidentales tenían razón y que él lo
negaba porque bueno pues él es un
maestro no del juego y de la mentira y
del disimulo y del despiste pero era
bastante claro que su interés su
intención era esa ahora me gustaría
referirme a cuáles son la pregunta que
hiciste hace rato cuáles son los
objetivos de putin a mí me parece que
claramente lo que busca es quien lo ha
dicho además abiertamente no lo que
quiere es que ucrania no se comprometa a
no a desistir de su interés de acercarse
a la unión europea ya la otan que
desista de recibir ayuda militar de
occidente
y también ha pedido que los países de la
otan de europa del este que recibe que
ahora tienen presencia militar
estadounidense también se deshagan de
esa presencia militar de la otan se
busca una especie de como decimos en
relaciones internacionales de colchones
de poner tierra de por medio entre rusia
y las tropas o las armas de la ocasión